uh one time you you met a a christian
uh pastor and you had a chance to talk
to her
yeah i talked to her you know and she
was a pastor from brazil she come to
give the big lecture over here she was a
scholar christian scholar
and i asked a simple question and say
can i ask you a question
cause i'm not even a student i know my
religion just a little bit
and i ask i say where the fundamental or
in your religion is
trinity right you say right say this is
the three gods and one and
all these kind of confusing things i say
can you explain this to me so she starts
explaining can i tell her okay i can ask
you one question
so yes do you follow the ten
commandments do you believe in them she
said yes
i said what the first commandment says
the first comment says the god is only
one
i said didn't this break the old trinity
mythology
and she got confused because she cannot
explain from before
then i go to the second commandment when
i tell them about i i
worship the idols i say so how it is if
the bible says in the second commandment
do not
worship the idols do not draw the
pictures not of what above meaning the
moon the stars the sun
the birds not even one uh on the bottom
meaning the
fishes the animals the human beings and
anything else so the bible telling you
do not do this while you're doing this
so my main question to her was do you
follow the bible and the teachings of
jesus christ
or you follow the church because it
seems you follow the church teachings
you know what innovation completely what
like jesus never wore the cross
jesus never eat the pork he was
circumcised
he was wearing the long taupe you know
what the muslim these days the arabs
dressing
he was having a long beard you know and
have even a scripture and matthew
i don't remember what scripture this is
in matthew i think 20 26 39
yeah when he prostrate yeah you know
what i mean the way we pray
yeah and he went a little further and he
fell on his face
and prayed to himself who's he praying
to the god
to his creator yeah and when he was
teaching the people how to pray
when he raised he what we do we call
this dua
the prayer to the god almighty and he
says what he was given the prayer of
father in heaven
and he give this prayer and then what
did he say he didn't say in the name of
jesus christ what do you say he said i
mean
that's what we do after prayer when we
do we say i mean
yeah that's it that's deep you know just
the lord's prayer if you
as as somebody who's trying to connect
with god let's say your background is
christianity
and you look at what you said the first
commandment
is that you shall have no other gods
except the one god and you won't worship
anything in the heavens
so what can that that can be stars
nature i mean the stars the sun
anything the birds the sun the anything
the angels the anything the people
worship these days you know anything
they see
and then it continues on nothing in the
sea nothing in the sea this means the
fishes like i saw sometime
i think the jehovah witnesses or baptist
people they put the fish in this
represented jesus
how will this represent the jesus if the
second commandment says do not
make the idols and this is explaining
the fish is true this is the word over
there
yeah so i don't know and then also
nothing in the earth
nothing in the earth that's the first
commandment of course
you know so nothing in the earth so i
don't know why people don't follow it
like i think they just blindly follow
the churches and they don't even open
the bible
because when i was a christian this what
threw me off when i actually opened the
bible and read it
i saw everything what they do in the
church this opposite of bible teach
this opposite of what jesus was teaching
the jesus come and say god is alpha and
omega
i don't do nothing except from his will
so anything miracle and anything he did
is because allah
the god almighty allow him to and he
says you know i'm human how many times
in the bible he's supposed to say i'm
human
and this is a scripture in the bible
says that god
is not a human he never born he never
died he's eternal
so don't you feel this contradiction he
says i'm a human and god says in the
bible i'm not a human
i can't die and i cannot born so why you
guys just
blindly follow it and just close your
eyes on the scriptures
you made another interesting observation
about him making gustle
uh evolution before prayer so yeah what
they say he was a baptized no he wasn't
every time uh where we okay if he was
do the baptized why after that he go to
the grave and start uh worship the god
to teach you how to pray
why this is exactly what i'm explaining
when we
uh go into the masjid every friday we
doing
this mean take a shower we completely
wash our
selves you know what i mean prepare to
the prayer put a clean clothes and we go
worship that's what we do you know on my
knees pray straight down we pray so this
is what exactly he did
he did the after that he go to the grave
and he
showed the people how to worship the god
almighty
this is in the bible this is in the
bible yeah
they thought he was a baptized you know
what i mean and like okay if he was a
baptist whereas there was the cross
wasn't there and all this where is this
innovation all come from
jesus teach the people to wearing the
cross to worshiping this cross
to tell them if i die you guys need to
follow that and that and that
you know what i mean like i i don't know
where's all this come from this is not
in the bible for sure
so so the main point here was trying to
get people
because obviously we love jesus as a
mighty messenger
and we love our brothers and sisters in
humanities that's why we're sharing this
message
and is to direct their worship to the
one
that jesus worshiped simple so instead
of worshiping jesus
worship the one jesus worshiped